ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
ah ah
this guy is taking it in ah
ah ah ah
how can i use it when it's pitch black and i can't see anything it
's an underground formation so i can see everything from here i'll
give you a share if i get Sihanouk just now hit me next  Hey, there's no room for trading
I just don't want to hit the tree Hurry up and take a bath Gratie The surfer who hits all the time
wh
[music]
You can hear the sound in 50 places
Take me over there 1 Matsumori you do yeah yeah yeah
[music]  ]
Hm, with a wound like this, I'll take the solo lever
and hold it for 10 minutes.
It's getting closer by I
'm used to fighting in a difficult darkness
Falling cautiously The only thing that hid my head was a large
one.
Teruzo
[music]